what's your favorite food
what if I said this episode was fishing
6 I would be excited join MC the guest
not do it yes we're gonna try fishing
tips of 3 different price points
dribbling he's like salivating he's so
excited
that's really about it come pasta for
the sound divers or someone days I'll
give you this out
[Music]
where are we man Chester Manchester why
is it he liked about fish and chips it's
got everything
the succulent steak and the hearty chip
my mr. Fisher chips
some Ozzy managing director of the hip
hop tip shop
[Music]
we kind of coin it as untraditional fish
and chips I mean that just gives us the
license to be creative we get marries
five potatoes we haven't come on Holly
finish off the 20 kilo back in 11
minutes and then we'll do their 130
degree fry and then chill the product
down and then we'll do another 180
degree advise us when you get like the
real crispness with a skin and the
fluffy inside way that we caught the
fish so we do it small bites a lot more
juice simply but I make sure that we
make fresh as well dairy and egg free
which kind of differentiates ourselves
with use this huge industrial blending
that is bigger than a logistic put into
the flour and then cut into our mixture
and it goes into the fryer from there
then it will just start to expand
another really crispy outside fresh
juicy fish in the middle
[Music]
today you're gonna be having a small
fishing ships with an internship use
with your pants he was hired No ah
there's good cop lots of different kinds
of yellow which I like too big chunky
bits of fish really good Cheers
all right I'll just dive into them
Cheers let's cut your mouth on it though
I don't want to choose that bit
that's a ridiculously good ship that is
the best trip I've ever had if a potato
wedge supposed to make off with a
fishing ship tip yeah it's potato every
chippy
it's soft here crispy succulent I know
this episode you're gonna call
everything succulent I love it when you
get a little crispy weird one is that
might not even be potato to do fish this
is like little dumplings the fish oh
look at that little nugget listen listen
again that Liz the really light fish
isn't it it's not fishy the drop is you
at all but oily but not too oily its
moist
not too moist yellow we're not together
but it's just very succulent oh my I
want to say succulent again
I'm trying to come up with a fish punch
I just need to mull it over a wood metal
fish joke
I just feel out of place I feel love is
healthy we are now on roots which is
French for on roots back to London [ __ ]
fat fish effects in the 1930s there were
actually 35,000 chip shops in the UK
I'll be more interested how many there
are now
[Applause]
I've got a joke I had a girlfriend a
lobster and then I flounder
[Music]
she loves her partner knew I knew lizard
like that my junk was off the hook
get out before I krill you had a place
and we're back in London we're now off
to our mid-range option tuna salmon stop
raining fish my name's Carrie I'm on
golden Union this is my stop in the
middle of Soho of hunting philosophies
the Queen kept me here next to that
build it does everyone when they think
English food they think fish and chips
why do you think that is during the
Second World War it was the one thing
they didn't russian russian the size of
your school card is gonna be six eight
ounces a features never person we like
it just all to be authentic impression
we make the batter from scratch we have
an opportunity that we do it to the
minute
the bear shakes it all eight seals and
when it seals it slowly cooks inside and
it seems itself it's tender its moist to
the flavor of the fish still in there
really dry as I kind of meant to sorry
you're really close to breathing in my
ear that we will take photos with Priam
Ramallah was a rumbler basically he's
thinking potatoes the man taking the
skin off for you otherwise you will be
there all day special blend or vegetable
all with a duck fat your chair is like a
roast potato and put on their fish and
chips for that mushy peas especially if
you're north of them one of our fries is
a member of the multipy societies we
soak them overnight
jamin and then we cook them really
slowly which shed loads of butter
yourself it pepper and that is it
today you guys are gonna be having a
single Cod and chips and then 1295
no eating it you got to think about the
presentation smell I support my favorite
ship that one will know you've touched
it that's obviously all on isn't it look
a lot as a lovely surprise
Maxo yes Cheers
[Music]
potatoes they're really like fluffy
chips and one word in the sound is so
tender in the middle oh my god that is
good but we have our vision juice is
quite versatile you can chop alphabet
you can done fun
everything is this amazing crunch of
crisp Ryan let's try the mushy peas just
please
yes peas you're going straight in from
the pot only this man eats from a
condiment pot it's so soft
the peas are superior I've never had
these like this there are some surprised
flavors in there it's a no best spice my
posh peas the chips are like 10 out of
10 fish 10:02 and mushy peas 10 out of
10 even the lemon I really like this
place
I think I'm home
two-in-one on filling it and fill it I
fill it I fill it it's not know so I
where are we going
Bishop's wrong this is in fact the most
expensive Asia place who
London Zoo show em listen bro she sells
seashells I'm Choi Davis the managing
director here at the seashell restaurant
in Marylebone famous for fish and chips
and the best efficient ships and
arguably the world down a lot of fish
and chips you love fish to juice my
favorite day is Friday ladies he's
trying to joke okay Nobby lady Carl has
been here ed sheeran Michael Jackson and
David yes he's had a mushy pea five-way
what is a mushy pea fight so it's very
much to be that each other and everyone
if you look at the fish like black cod I
mean the real name is sable fish place
nickname is Blackwood they swim up to
3,000 meters and they completely black
the skin because there's no natural
sunlight because of the rarity of it
it's quite a bespoke item it's got a
mild flavour it's more of a flavour than
normal Cod and chips and it's very
buttery very soft on the palate the
batter we make here it's our secret
recipe - it's a special type of flour
with the baking powder and colder the
water the better and we choose you to
fry and panko tend to fry in about 175
282 degree we put it in for about seven
to eight minutes a lot of its based on
experience you can see when the fish is
ready anyway and when you're happy with
it because of the fat content and the
mild flavor and texture it's just
completely different
Plato's we get them from British farms
we just use the colleague fish to boil
about six to nine minutes so today
you'll be having the black cod with
chips and mushy peas and that would be
at a price point of fifty pounds it's
time he's very very excited
I love the fact that it is on a
newspaper
shai said a lot of people actually would
have tea with fish and chips but we
opted for beer
it's doubt on a chart
[Music]
I'm salt and pepper again other than you
can never have enough of this that was
quite long first time I look at it so
which one's the best that one fine
you've already claimed that chase yes
I'll calm man
a lot of real bounce to them when you
got a little bit crunch on the outside
and then it's nicely soft on the inside
right I'm going to look at
oh my god succulent
I'll go succulent they really succulent
yeah yeah this fish is the one that
doesn't see life and swims down the
bottom of the ocean whatever he's doing
down there he tastes different it's a
sexy fish never found a booster to be
like that fish that is a sexy fish the
panko is really crunchy if you will you
opt for Penn Cove batter on all
Persinger yeah nice good batter
normally I don't think about the batter
this made me realize I need to respect
the batter
though the we've had an adequate amount
of fish fighting so far in this tasting
role our sole I'm pulled to the brim out
of this celebrity guest you think
Stephen Fry came was he caught a fish
with no eyes window eyes
[Music]
that was great he's literally eating
mine technically loose gets the last
piece you do animal Geronimo all the
places were amazing but which is the
most worth it to you what am I saying
this is my favorite I loved all of it
it's hard to decide you go first
I really like the hip hop chip shop I
love saying it hip hop hip drop but my
worth it winner discordant Union I loved
it I tasted the best for me
glass breaks I love the expensive one I
love see Xiao Lu's succulent you think
all three were succulent I think all
three recyclable but my winner would be
hip-hop tip-top there's booze you're
worth it winner pork chip shop one word
to describe its place go hip-hop shoe
shop cool dawn Union style it C sharp
for every kind cool I mean I tell you
what they like us three are they cool
stylish
[Music]